yeah thank you I hope you had a
refreshing lunch break and I'm happy to
see so many of you here so yeah the
title of my talk ten years of automatic
category classification for product data
quite a mouthful
yeah we're dealing with product data for
quite some time now at salute and I'm
going to talk about the evolution of our
architecture and system evolving around
around
automatic carrier classification so
Christian all that he introduced me a
little bit so yeah my name is Johannes
and I work for salute for almost four
years now and those are some some brands
of salute so they're the bidding I de
shopping the advanced communication ever
but most interestingly our talk will
deal with the stuff that in the end is
on beleaguered OTE for the non-germans
because it's cheaper dot de so it's
price comparison website so people come
to the website looking for some specific
product and finding at our site the shop
that provides this offer with the
cheapest price for example you can also
browse and when someone then clicks on a
link and goes to the shop and the shop
is happy to get a customer because
people are usually willing to buy when
they come from our side then the shop
share some of the revenue of the sell
and that's like our business model we
sent some user traffic to the shops and
say send us money which is quite simple
model but it's working so that's nice so
today believe that the e looks something
like this
so you have some like an overview of our
categories and thinks you might browse
so this is also like a use case if you
want to just find out what our current
models for something and if you want to
filter for something you can do that and
on the right there's like the latter
view on our category
our main categories that users can
browse through so that's the state of
2019 but as the company was founded in
2004 we are here for quite some time so
back then this is the image from around
2007 I think things looked a bit
different so they are like mobile phones
that weren't just a screen but they had
buttons Wow
and some of you might remember but
already there at the top you might see
there were categories so here we have
like Handy's so mobile phones without
the contract was like category you could
browse through so things were simpler
back then so let's have a look at the
architecture so the main website was
just this there was like a master
database MySQL back then and a search
service and this is just website
architecture from around 2008 I'm not
exactly sure because as you might have
noticed if I'm working for almost 4
years in the company in this about last
10 years I wasn't around back then but I
talked to some people who were and
learned about a lot and it was quite an
interesting journey and that's what this
is also a little bit about so how did we
get the data into the master database
that yeah is used for serving Billy
Garrity there was obviously there are
the shops providing all the catalogs
giving us the data but there was a third
party involved and this shirt body
downloaded the data and sorted them into
categories and products and then solute
imported this and as you see there's
like this shadow database so what's this
about like then the architecture looked
at is the import needed to be like
complete until you could use the
imported data
so they import data into this shadow
database and then when it was like the
import was done they just switched the
mast and in the shadow so that was
master became the shadow and the shadow
became the master and then all the data
on Bilodeau te was current with very
nice right but in my imagination it
looked a little bit like this huh now
change so I'm not sure how easy is
single rare but of course all of this
was automated at least that I heard but
things that design differently nowadays
right and this had problems one thing is
there was a huge lag so imports only
took place every four hours and if shop
updates the price and we were price
comparison website then four hours plus
maybe some lack of the download before
makes the shop unhappy because they want
to say hey we the cheapest now where is
it on your side then when the third
party made some errors at the
categorization or in the in the product
creation there was not good a good easy
way to to give some feedback there was
no API just people need to talk to each
other there's an error or whatever so
this wasn't really convenient back then
and also the third party of course also
had a share of the revenue and as a
company you want to cut the middleman
right so the decision was made to do
some in-housing here so we need to
replace all of the things that the third
party did so into the system to download
shop data during this shop import and we
need to replace the shirt body black box
the categorization which was called
mapping in the following because like
you know as a set of categories and you
have some offers streaming in and you
want to map the category to the
offer so this is this kind of stack it's
actually a bit too coarse-grained for
what it really is because the
categorization that okay
mapping is a name that was used and
they're sorting the offers into product
products so a bunch of offers that
describe the same thing are considered
to be a product and this was called
matching was liked by the matched
together and this was called our agonist
matching project our very own matching
project and let's see how this went so
like the first step was creating the
shopping porch and we needed to have the
data in our and so result from that was
like having a base of all the data the
shops gave us and also we can create
Delta's now so especially for updating
the website and the search and
everything having tells us is way faster
than waiting for the complete import
cycle so there were already some wins in
this but still the third party was in
place but because we have these deltas
now we needed to coordinate the data
that's already here and that's coming
through there so there's like another
process called matching export to find
this together then replacing the third
party what did we need need to do next
so from the deltas we knew okay which
offers have changed which should we look
at and those have changed we first
checked for it's a change relevant
because I mean offer what were usually
consists of some base information like
what's the name what's like the category
assigned by the shop or every offer has
a price and there's something like
delivery time and some of those fields
aren't relevant for the category or the
product so the deliver deliver is the
delivery time changed you don't need to
change the category or the product of an
offer so only the relevant changes
should be considered for our systems to
be put
and then we need to have the mapping and
the matching so find out the calorie and
the product and everything needs to be
stored somewhere so that was also
introduced the so called mapping and
matching DB short mm DB which will stay
with us for quite a while so this design
fixes most problems so the huge lag
problem goes away with dealing with
little shops directly ourselves and not
just in part of your ours and yeah the
third parties come more money for us
so but the does this does not really fix
the problem with correcting errors I
mean when we have own systems assuming
that you have some classifier that works
you still need some way to deal with
errors okay so this is like the start of
the architecture and we will not focus
on everything around there but talk a
little bit more about the mapping
classifier that was created in and went
live in 2009 so the choice of algorithm
back then was a support vector machine
and the approach was was like using this
one versus many classification so it's
obvious it's you can model this
categorization as a classification task
so yeah we had like more than 2000
categories in our back-end and you need
to predict these classes for each other
so yeah it's kind of obvious to use this
state-of-the-art back then support of a
machine and the good thing is we still
have the third-party data from before so
we have labels for each offer there's a
category already there so yay so much
training data pretty pretty nice for
start
so there was one model trained per
category so it's like more than 2,000
models were trained in a 1 versus many
way so each model answers like the
question should this offer be in the
category you're representing and yeah
you classify an offer with each of the
model and pick the best ranking score
and for each of the model you can also
could also set an acceptance threshold
because yeah you mind to want to adjust
that I'm will mention it played a little
bit so what features were used so it was
actually just backwards you throw all
the tokens you find in different fields
into one bag of words and try to lean
you learn how they can help to identify
the category so you have some attracting
we're tokens and some repelling tokens
in there and that you want to learn so
use the name description and the shop
category which like the category that
the shop delivers from their system
because usually every shop has its own
kind of categorization scheme and we
need to yeah
unify that and what also is helping
throwing into the mix of the backwards
price bin tokens so using the price but
not like the sec price because it would
be much much too fine-grained but used
like winnings from 0 to 5 euro 5 to 10
years and so on
yeah we have some spam and this was just
created as a token and thrown to the
back to be learned from and that's it so
in like 2008-2009 what were some
challenges they had to overcome so back
then the pison ecosystem it hadn't
really found it's love for machine on
yet so numpy and scikit-learn and all of
these beautiful tools we have nowadays
didn't exist back then or not
we're nearly as far as they are today
today so they needed to use something
else
the plinian implementation the lip as
for M in C or C++ so as we are in our
core a Python company this is like
different technology that was used and
we usually do but it was really
necessary back then because yeah there
was nothing else around
then for parallelization and
pre-processing all the data there was a
MapReduce framework called disco and it
was by Nokia this anybody here know it
never heard of it
ok and at least two people out of three
worked at salute or work at salute so
you don't count so one person heard of
it so yeah it pretty much got
discontinued in 2014 but we were stuck
with it but back then it was like you
want this Python and MapReduce what's
the thing so disco was introduced also
on a sir even on server 16 gigabytes Ram
was huge is like a quote of a the
colleague who provided me miss most
information about this talk so to do
some parallel training for the SVM
classifiers they created like this
custom memory mapped binary file format
and so all the processes could work with
the same data and so there was quite a
lot of engineering needed to to get this
working
but then okay they did their
infrastructure they worked on the data
and so on it's a cross validation for
each category he looked at it as a
precision recall ratio is it good as
mentioned they they had the true labels
from the third party so that was easy to
compare
and then some some retired staff need to
adjust the thresholds for each category
so for some categories false positives
are more costly than for others so you
might want to have a high threshold for
some categories and the one for others
for example back then we had like this
certificate which guaranteed there's no
erotic stuff on our webpage so we really
had to make sure that everything that's
for marital hygiene is categorized into
the correct category erotic and filtered
out and never shows up on our webpage so
in there you adjust the threshold to be
a little bit lower so you make sure
everything really goes into that
category that needs to be there then
there's 2009 mapping classifying goes
live so this was like the system's
architecture so what happened next
yeah living data then of course the
product world is ever changing so new
stuff comes out new developments I mean
today there's like smart home staff and
electric scooters didn't exist back then
so there's always some change so also
the source of Labor Tatum and it's
because hey we achieved our goal we got
rid of the search party but now we need
new training data so how to get that
especially when you want to add a new
category there's nothing there and the
other thing is okay the system will
perfect I mean what's just like needed
to be good enough to replace the other
system so there were errors and they
ended up on the webpage and then were
people saying oh there's an error on the
webpage this needs to be cleaned up
immediately so the there was kind of the
understanding that stuff needed to
fixed and corrected fast so there were
editorials added to the mix so there's
editorial stuff category managers and
and so like who are experts for the
details of specific kinds of products
and categories and they say okay this
needs a anta-kale into the data and fix
errors and confirm documents okay this
category is correct for this and they
work work through the data and yeah as
this it happens all these confirming and
correcting data was designed to be the
new training data because a human expert
has decided this is correct so we can
say okay then let's use this label as
the training data and that was a rather
stay blocky texture this was running and
as a whole like the thing from 2009 to
2010 so this is like the 10 years of
category classification from a better
title I mean under the hood a lot of
things changed
but this rough architecture didn't so
like this MMD beam was MySQL and later
switched to Postgres and so on some
tweaks are done the editorial tools
evolved but the core was pretty much
untouched especially the training
infrastructure with like the disco and
and and mapping training was a little
bit stuck so there was a decision to
rewrite the mapping classify into zone
18 we needed to replace this unflexible
infrastructure because even if you had a
good idea what how you could improve
everything it was very hard to integrate
anything because like neon you need to
drive it to see you need to look into
the memory files and so on and there was
a lot of technical tab we need to get a
rid disco which couldn't even be run on
the recent linux anymore
and replies nan Python tools because I
think when this system would build it
felt like our we climbed the mountain we
really achieved something but if you
then stop going on you're more like
stuck in quicksand because you start
thinking in technical depth so that's
what happened so I think I need to speed
up a little bit so we thought about a
new design introducing a new category
classify and using neural network based
model and the structure we thought is
fine it's working let's keep an eye keep
this so we trained and neural network
based classifier and used again
name-brand shop category description as
the fields included price bidding which
is useful include position information
so that's improvement no more just bag
of words and another change was no two
thousand different classifiers anymore
one classifier was now handing out one
result over all classes which is rather
nice for comparing the results but
during development we found many
problems in the training data there was
wrongly labeled data yeah
simply wrong label wrong class for
something then we had a problem with
semantically overlapping categories so
if you look at this we have a category
books Spanish books books French books
and books foreign language books because
the German company everything that's not
German is like foreign language at least
how it was modeled in the category tree
but if you have a French book where does
it belong at the French books category
or in the foreign language books
category so how should it classify I
decide when a human couldn't decide then
they are dumping ground categories for
example if you have more with mobile
phone accessories like there are bags
for mobile phone covers up screens
holders charges whatever and all of this
was put into like a mobile phone
accessory which means the stuff within
that category was very orthogonal to
each other it wasn't similar so if you
train the model that should
what is a mobile phone accessory and
stuff within that category is very far
away from each other it's hard to learn
and then there's an imbalance of
features distribution within a category
this is another problem because often
when the editorial staff was cleaning up
data they did it shop wise so take this
shop and correct the categories or of
the offers of this shop and then a lot
of data of one shop landed into the
training data and then this shop
specific information might have been the
dominant feature for example the shop
category for something was learned to be
a very good indicator for a category but
maybe it's to shop specific in the real
data that looks different for but for
for offers it should be the same ok so
there's also an imbalance of carrier
distribution over the whole data set so
there are some categories where we have
a lot of training data and some so I
over sampled compared to the real data
and there's other categories that are
under sampled when here's the thing if
we have editorial staff working with
this why is our training data such a
mess
it's really unbelievable right and the
bottom line and that's like the
important thing we learned the business
goal you gave our editorial staff we fix
the data so the last look nice on
billiard RT and the data science part of
us said you should constantly adapt the
category to the reality and maintain
training data fetch category but it
didn't happen one reason was
insufficient ruling there was product
based tooling where you edited the most
important products which means most sold
products and category centered editing
where do mass edits that's where the
most errors come from and also
maintenance is cumbersome so an extended
period of time the urgent things product
the important things so I think
have to skip a little bit now due to
time but what we need to do was we need
to rethink our whole training data
management so we need to change a
Detroiter staffs role they need to
manage the category and prove training
data instead of fixing life data so to
do that we said we need don't need like
these edits our training data approach
anymore we need to remove like these
direct connections and say we need
annotation tasks so the systems should
monitor the quality and if the of the
results and if the quality is not good
generate annotation tasks for editorial
staff and then the editorial staff
should work like in an active learning
setting on the on the right things to do
so in March of this year we went live
with a new model but with the old
architecture as you can see we're still
like in this fixing things mode because
it's hard to switch this in a fast but
we're planning to add more like this
active learning goals there in this year
and moving forward but let's jump to the
takeaways so think about your training
data management if you are in it for
long term you there some mistakes to be
avoided so think about your systems life
cycle easier I mean if you're working on
your PhD gather some data make an
experiment and and report the result you
don't have a training data life cycle
that's long but in our case we had a
moving target and Ageing data so you
need to think about this beforehand and
if your domain is changing over time
make sure your tank data keeps up and
especially think about how to delete all
data because it's harder to do that and
also investing in technology transitions
the cost time but they come with a
flexibility because just after we
changed a lot and remove technical depth
we revitalized the creativity of the
team so it really made a difference
and then a well found decision to
improve the status kill but you need to
be challenged in the pronoun them
because some things we even didn't fix
now or are on the verge of fixing the
hard to correct errors we still don't
have an API but the annotation has kind
of represented so thanks for listening
to my talk and are some special things
go on to Patrick Sheamus who gave me
many of the information about the old
its system and also Christian was here
who was a big part of the new model
creation so thank you for listening
thanks a lot your honors we have time
for one question Olli and I think you
were the first person to raise your hand
so it's your question think about it
really well alright first of all thanks
for the great talk just out of curiosity
you have any measure on accuracy like
how well did your system perform yes we
do that yeah reporting details numbers
didn't fit into the time of the talk
therefore head left amount what our
accuracy measures it depends on the
category like the 2005 categories + so
in some it's like 99 percent and if
everything is fine and in others it's
worse but one thing that dramatically
changed between the old and the new
system was like things that we couldn't
put into a category in the old system
well there was like I was it didn't met
the threshold
we're binning it no category for you but
the new system we changed like from 80%
categorization rates to like 95 97 % of
categorization rate so that's the
biggest improvement that I can report
just like this and for everything else
we can talk at some in some other
context yeah you can approach me if you
have any questions afterwards I'm here
yeah thanks a lot
you